this is grandmaster daniel neriditskiy
and we are watching magnus carlson
taking on hikaru nakamura at the 2010
fide world blitz championship you can
see the crowd gathered around them and a
handshake goes on and the arbiter star
starts the clock magnus of the white
pieces as he plays e4 hikaru known for
his incredibly versatile opening
repertoire as he plays a french magnus
responds with knight c3 the main line
and the steinis variation by hikaru
knight f6 magnus closes up the center
with e5
supports it with f4 and they're
following a very well known theoretical
continuation blitzing out the moves and
now the queen likely to appear on b6 but
he carries uses a sideline with a6 b5
expanding on the queen side this is
still very well known you can see the
nonchalance with which they're making
the moves but now the first surprise of
the game is he karu strikes at the king
side g5 trying to break up magnus's
central pawn chain and he succeeds in
doing so magnus recaptured with the pawn
which is a little bit surprising now
hikaru takes that very valuable pawn on
e5 and he's got a pretty big center here
in the early going you can see hikaru
with pawns on e6 and d5 and magnus
really has no answer for that and that
knight on e5 is a lot of prospects it
can move to g4 it can move to c4 and
magnus that gave him a little bit little
bit of pauses he spent 10 seconds or so
on bishop d3 continuing his development
now a big question is going to be which
way are the sides going to castle or
there is the answer from magnussee
castle's kingside but ikaru's king is
also probably going to castle king side
even though hikaru's kingside pawn
structure is a little bit damaged he
misses a jeep on but look at that dark
sword bishop on g7 it's going to provide
the black king a lot of shelter if he
car if and when hikaru chooses to castle
kingside but right now hikara was
thinking he's not castling yet maybe
he's contemplating knight g4 if he can
get rid of magnus's dark squad bishop
then that knight on d4 is going to lose
a key supporter a key team player in
hikaru with the longest think of the
game so far and there he goes with
knight g4
attacking that bishop on e3 and the
problem for magnus is that if he moves
that bishop up to f4 it's going to
become susceptible to a fork hikaru
could advance that e pawn up to e5 you
could also play queen d8 to b6 a move
that i thought he would play a lot
earlier but that move could come at the
least pleasant moment with that being
said i still think magnus should try to
keep his dark square bishop alive at all
costs as he takes a quite a while and
this move leans back in his chair
a little bit of exasperation frustration
there for magnus unclear where he went
wrong but he doesn't like what he sees
as cecaro has developed tremendous peace
activity and for a french he's gotten a
fantastic position and magnus responds
with a very calm move king h1 and he
agrees to part ways with his dark square
bishop now i would take that bishop at
the first available opportunity right
now because if he carved delays then
magnus is going to drag his bishop back
to g1 and hikaru wastes no time as he
trades the dark squid bishop i like
hikaru's position here as he moves his
queen up to e7 covering the x-ray that
white's queen was exerting on black's
king and stopping shenanigans related to
the knight on d4 moving to f5 now
hikaru's king is safe for the time being
even though it's in the center magnus
moves his other knight up to g3 ikaro
casting a glance up at his opponent
before moving his bishop up to e5
centralizing it look at that knight on
d7 supporting its compatriot on e5
magnus under pressure he's a little bit
lower not even a little bit he's 40
seconds down on the clock as he
continues to think
and hikaru looking pretty confident his
position looking good what's interesting
is that hikaru still hasn't castled
maybe he's flirting with the concept of
castling queenside that's totally not
out of the question now that magnus
lacks a dark scored bishop which would
have been a very effective piece with
which to attack black's king on the
queen side so hikaru i can guarantee you
that he's thinking about which way he
should castle or maybe he won't castle
at all maybe hikaru will decide that his
king is safer in the center than on
either of the flanks this is a big
decision he carried with the two bishops
a big center but with a slightly exposed
king and he carries light scored bishop
well if that long diagonal opens it's
going to be a beast but for the time
being it's still pretty passive the
clock beginning to equalize cairo is
taking 30 seconds this is a critical
moment he senses it what will he do he's
about to make a move and that move is
rookie in hikaru forfeits his
opportunity to castle king's side
because when you move a rook you can't
castle to that same side but instead he
decides to target that pawn on g5 he
decides that controlling the g-file is
even more important than castling and so
unless he castles queen queenside it's
very likely that hikaru will keep his
king in the center for the foreseeable
future maybe for the rest of the game we
will see you could see the spectators
they are captivated by what's going on
on the board and magnus with another
long think as his clock approaches a
minute a very concerning position here i
don't know if white can afford to lose
the g pawn because if he loses it then
hikaru's pieces will acquire a new found
activity that bishop on e5 and that rook
which will appear on g5 are going to
exert tremendous pressure on the knight
on g3 but if magnus plays h4 then he
weakens his own knight on g3 and hikaru
could respond by pushing his own h pawn
up to h6 and magnus he continues to
think he's now down to 50 seconds it's
so so dangerous to get this low on the
clock with ikar nakamura he knows how to
put pressure in his opponent's time
pressure and
he's just better on the board magnus in
trouble here he as his clock ticks down
to 40 seconds and the spectators kind of
uneasy in their seats waiting for the
world champion to make a move he's down
to 30 seconds he still doesn't know what
to do if you play h4 will he give up g5
he looks at the clock he sees the
urgency and he finally plays h4 but what
answer will he have to h6 what if hikaru
tries to get rid of that g-pawn at all
costs look at that knight on g3 it's
only protected by a queen and it is
hungrily eyed by that bishop on e5 and
that rook on g8 and ikaru is up a full
minute on the clock he's got plenty of
time to think here h6 looks really good
and hikaru plays it without delay magnus
sacrificing the knight in the center but
is that a desperation sacrifice i think
it is what if hikaru just moves his
queen up to e6 what is magnus's
follow-up going to be that bishop on e5
it's a key defender and hikaru no you
just placed queen c5 look at that knight
on d7 magnus shakes his head that knight
is defending both the queen and the
bishop magnus is down a piece what does
he have to show for it he's got 20
seconds on the clock his clock is
ticking down he's looking at the clock
the spectators are looking at the clock
he doesn't know what to do he's down to
pc caro is on the road to winning this
game and magnus sees knows nothing
better than to trade queens and he grabs
the second pawn on h6 it's not over yet
we know of magnus's resilience he's got
two puns for the piece the rook is
attacked f7 is attacked hikaro very
likely to move his rook up to g7 he
hesitates briefly he still has over a
minute on the clock he plays for kj now
magnus can't take on f7 with the rook
because if rook takes h6 so oh and his
bishop was hanging too and that gives
cicaro a chance to save his fpon and
magnus desperately trying to centralize
his remaining reserves bringing all the
toys to the nursery party it's not over
yet hikaru realizes that he still has to
play accurately perhaps 94
clogging up the e file even further
another glance of the clock from magnus
he senses the desperation
and hikaru it seems that with only a
couple more accurate moves he should be
able to consolidate his extra piece and
he sacrifices in exchange on e6 and now
he brings the knight up to e4 magnus
moves his king away there was a fork
threatened hikaru hesitating a little
bit he's probably going to bring his own
king up to the center now hikaru has two
minor pieces for a rook but look at the
activity of those minor pieces a knight
in the center a bishop on e5 and those
age puns are sitting ducks as he karu
illustrates with his last move rookie
trade attacking h6 but now knight g3
knight g3 is gonna trap the rook
and force magnus to re-sacrifice an
exchange hikaru doesn't even have to
hurry with that move look at that rook
on h5 it's totally trapped but he cargo
down to 40 seconds he's getting a little
bit nervous and magnus has done a great
job of defending thus far but can he
survive with 10 seconds on the clock in
a still a worse position hikaru drags
his king over to f7 he was threatening
king g6 magnus defends his rook supports
it by pushing his jeep on up but the
prospect of knight g3 still really
scares me that would trap the rook and
magnus is probably planning to give that
rook up for the bishop on e5 hikaru he
brings his bishop out of dodge and now
knight g3 is even a more terrifying
threat it's five seconds for magnus as
he plays bishop b3 attacking d5 hikaru
has to defend it he plays 92 there's a
fork on f3 oh and magnus's bishop is
attacked three seconds on the clock he
brings it back to d1 he manages to press
the clock in time but now his pieces are
at an all-time low in terms of their
passivity and hikaru can take on h6 he
can bring his king up to g6 but he's
down to 15 seconds and he does take on
h6 and we have a rook train and magnus
is still not out of the game but he's
about to flag any flanks he flags and he
points to his own clock and he was
already worse but what a game this was
and if you enjoyed this game please
click on the links in the playlist thank
you so much for watching